Hi. In this lecture, we're gonna compare
and contrast the three ways we've thought
about modeling people. So remember we
talked about first people being rational,
people having objective functions, and
optimizing with respect to their
objectives. Then we talked about how
that's somewhat unrealistic. We talked
about the behavior models, and I tend to
think of these as rationality plus, where
we sort of assume rational behavior but
then we add in a bias, or rationality
minus, is sort of being a little bit below
rational behavior. And then the third
thing we did is we said well you know,
maybe we could even go simpler and we
could just assume that people follow
rules. These could be fixed rules. They
could be adaptive rules. And when you
write down a model, you could say here's
the rule that people follow. Now in some
cases, the rule that people follow will be
rational. In some cases, the rule that
people follow will be behavioral. In other
cases, the rule that people follow will
just be some rule that we made up. What
I'm going to do in this lecture is I'm
gonna ask does it matter. Does it matter
which rules we write down? Does it matter
whether you have rule based behavior,
optimizing behavior, or behavioral models?
Well, the answer is it depends. And one of
the reason why we model is to figure out
how much does it matter how effectively we
model, or how accurately we model I should
say. So, let me do two examples. First,
I'm going to talk about a market, just a
pure exchange market. And then I'm going
to talk about a game, called Race to the
Bottom. You're gonna see in the market, it
really doesn't matter that much how we
model behavior, but in the Race to the
Bottom. You're going to see, it matters a
lot. So let's get started. So a two-sided
market. What is a two-sided market? Well,
a two-sided market has a group of buyers;
and these are people who want to buy some
good. And let's suppose. Just for the sake
or argument, that these buyers in the
setting have prices between zero and $100,
that means they're willing to pay
somewhere between zero and $100 for this
good. Now in addition to the buyers, there
are some sellers and let's suppose the
sellers are wiling to sell. For between
50, and 150 miles. So now let's think
about, what would rationale people do. So
those people who are complete rationale,
in this setting. How would they behave?
Well. If you're a buyer. You basically be
it a little bit less. Right then your true
value because you'd try and make a little
bit of money. And if you're a seller,
you'd probably ask for a little bit more
than your true value. And how much more or
less you ask for is gonna depend on, you
know, what the distributions of these
buyers and sellers are. So if you're fully
informed about what other people, what
these distributions are, you're gonna
shade in particular ways. Now what's gonna
happen is, let's suppose that people keep
on calling out prices until the market
clears. Until the number of goods sold,
that people want to sell at that price is
exactly equal to the number of goods
bought. The way it's going to work is each
person calls out each buyer calls out a
price their willing to buy at, each seller
calls out, a price they are willing to
sell at, and then we pick some sort of
price in the middle so we get an even
number of buyers and sellers. But what's
going to happen in the situation is that
the only buyers, that are gonna have a
value of at least 50 since people are
rational, the only buyers that are
actually gonna be, be able to buy anything
are going to have a value of about 50. So
the relevant buyers. Are gonna have values
in 50 to 100. So we only need to worry
about these people. So we can call these B
star. And the relevant sellers are gonna
be the only ones that advise between 50
and 100 as well. Because the ones that
have values above 100, from 100 to 150,
they want too much. Nobody, nobody's
willing to pay that much for their goods.
[inaudible], people are gonna call out
these prices, and what we're probably
gonna get is we're probably gonna get a
price of around 75, right? Where some of
the buyers buy, some of sellers sell, but
not all of them do. Let's suppose instead
we assume people are biased, that they're
not super strategic in figuring out
exactly how much to shave their bids. Well
then what people would probably do is they
might rely on sort of focal bids. So
people would be more likely to bid like
50, or 60 or 70 or 75. Even increments.
So, let me be more specific. So it might
be that if your rational buyer your value
is 56 that what you should do is you
should say I'm willing to pay 53.72 cents
Right you solve some really fancy
mathematical equation. [inaudible] That's
exactly your optimal bid. Well a
behavioral person might not do all that.
Ask. And it might say well my value's 56
so I'll bid 52 or I'll bid 50, 55, right.
Just some focal number. They're not going
to do all the math. Well again, if there's
just those slight deviations, you're still
probably going to see a price of about
$75. So optimizing behavior and sort of
slight behavioral bias is not going to be
a big difference. What about rule based
behavior? Well this has actually been
studied using a simple rule base called
zero intelligence agents. This is ZI,
we'll abbreviate it. So zero intelligence
agents work as follows. If you're a
bidder, what you do is you just sort of,
if you're a buyer, what you do is just
basically say okay, I'm just going to pick
some random amount less than my value. And
if you're a seller, you just pick some
random amount more than your value. So if
you're a buyer, and your value's 40.
Right, so if I'm the buyer who's value's
40, I might say, oh, I'm willing to buy it
for twenty. And if I'm a seller who's
value's 60, I might say, oh I'm willing to
sell it for 63. So what happens is, is you
just choose some random amount. What turns
out if you analyze the [inaudible] market
with. >> These zero intelligent traders.
What you end up getting is something with
a price pretty close to 75 and not that
different from what you'd get with
rational actors. So, in a two sided
market, right, [inaudible] and things, you
know, we've got models in economics, we've
got sort of supply and demand curves and
things like that where we get some price.
It turns out the market itself has so much
influence. The institutions have so much
influence. The behavior really doesn't
matter a great deal within some fairly
wide range of [inaudible]. So in markets,
we don't care as much about [inaudible]
behavior. But now in games, we do. So
let's do a specific game, it's called the
race to the bottom game, and here's how it
works. You pick a number between zero and
a hundred, the whole group, the group of
people in the room. Each person's gonna
pick a number between zero and a hundred,
whoever's closest to two thirds of the
mean. Wins. Alright, so what do you do?
Little quiz, what do you do in this
situation? Well. Let's, let's look. So
what does a rational person do. So if a
rational person is gonna be in this
situation it turns out is bid zero. Why is
that. Well, it's a completely symmetric
game. Everybody's got the exact same
sentence, everybody is rational, everybody
should be doing the same thing. So suppose
everybody was picking six. If everybody
was picking six, then the mean would be
six. If the mean is six, two-thirds of six
is four, so if you're rational and you
know everybody's picking six you should
pick two-thirds of six so you should pick
four. So, but then if everybody, then
everybody should pick four. But if
everybody's picking four, then you should
guess two-thirds of four, right? Which is
8/3. [inaudible] of everybody else. If
everybody's picking 8/3 then you should
give two-thirds of 8/3, and so on, and so
forth, and so on. Until eventually you get
down to everybody should be bidding, 0's.
That's what rational [inaudible] would be.
What would bias behavior be? Well, if you
were sort of. Not strategic at all. I'm,
super biased in this situation. Say, okay.
Fifteen and a number between zero and 100.
I don't know [inaudible] thing. I'm
confused. What I'm going to do is I'm
going to guess 50. And in fact if you
watch people play this game there's a
certain percentage of people who do guess
50. And in fact, you know, I've done this
in my classroom a whole bunch of times and
you'll get a significant percentage of
people who just say I'm going to guess 50.
Now, what would a behavioral rule be in
this situation? What would a rule based
behavior be? Well, again this is the
instance studied a lot and a rule that
people tend to study is this. They say
well, you know, people should guess 50. If
everybody guesses 50, I should guess
two-thirds of 50, so therefore I should
guess 33. So you see a lot of people guess
33. But then there's a lot of other people
who say "you know what everybody should
guess, is going to guess, so if everyone's
going to guess 33, I should guess
two-thirds of 33". Which is 22 and so if
you look at. With the experiment, you see
sum 50, sum 33, sum 22's in some. Right
two thirds of 22 is fourteen so you see,
some people actually say this. Look,
people should guess 50 [laugh], so some
[inaudible] should guess 50, I guess two
thirds of 50 which is 33. [inaudible]
Everybody should guess 33. So then I guess
two thirds of 33 which is 22. If anybody's
gonna guess 22. So I guess two thirds of
22 which is fourteen. Now of course if we
kept going with this we get to the
rational behavior eventually, which is
zero. Right? And, in fact if you played
this long enough these number do creep
down to zero, but they don't, typically
don't get there. You have to run them a
lot of times. So it's interesting here is,
the behavior we see is, this rule is sort
of a mix of rationale. And the buyer. So
the buyer's thing is to get 50. So people
sort of start with the base three by 50
stays in the middle. After that they start
sort of test responding. Never on an
adaptive rule for learning what?s the best
response. So the best responsibility, best
responsibility ?cause its 50 is to choose
33. And the best response ?cause choosing
33 is to choose 22 and so on. So here's
what we see, is the rules that people use
to sort of start up with the [inaudible]
buyers Someone rational. Let's do
something really fun here. [laugh] So
let's suppose we have two rational people
in this game and one irrational person. So
let's suppose you're sitting in a
[inaudible] space with three people and
you're a rational person, let's say you've
seen this game before, you know how it
works. And you're playing with me and you
know I've seen this game before and I know
how it works. But there's this third
person sitting in the room and this third
person we don't know anything about. We
know that they haven't seen the game
before and they, you know. Here are the
instructions. And we're both looking at
him trying to figure, what is this person
going to do? Well. Let's try and analyze
this. So suppose I'm a rational person,
and you're a rational person. So we're
gonna pick sum amount R, right? Now, the
other person, the [inaudible] person,
you've gotta make some decision, like,
what do you we think they're gonna pick?
Well, suppose we both think they're gonna
pick X. Well, if they're gonna pick x, we
have to decide how much do we pick, what
do we pick. Well, here's what has to be
true. The amount we pick r has to be two
thirds of r plus r plus x, right? Because
it's gotta be two thirds of the sum of
everybody else's, divided by three. So
it's gotta be two thirds of the mean, so
it's gotta be two thirds of r plus r plus
x, divided by three. So if I multiply this
out, I'm gonna get nine r. Has got to
equal 2xR+R+X, right. And so I'm going to
get, this ends up being 4R so I'm going to
get 5R=2X. So R equals. 2x over five. So
what that means is we both think "oh, this
other person is". What, I don't know.
Totally irrational, supposed to think the
other person is gonna choose 50. We think
the other person is gonna choose 50. Then
r equals two times 50 over five, r is
gonna equal twenty. Right, so if the other
person chooses 50. And we both choose
twenty, the sum will be 90. Right, so the
average is 30. And so two thirds of the
mean will be twenty. So why did I give
this example. Just think back. If
everybody is rational, the mean is zero.
The mean bid is zero and two-thirds of the
mean is zero and we split the money. But
here we throw in one irrational person,
then we no longer get zero. Right? We get
something a lot bigger than zero, because
the rational people have to take into
account what the other person's bid is
gonna be, and so they want to make their
bid as a function of that, and that drives
up their bid which drives up the mean,
which in term drives up their bid. So,
what's the lesson we take away? I think
the simple lesson is this, that rational
behavior is a really good benchmark. But
it's also important to included biases in
our model. Think about, are there biases
that would be relevant. And it's also
important to think about what if we just
write down a simple rule. And then if we
compare these three things. Rationale
behavior, bias. Right, and then simple
rule. And we see, well, how much
difference do we see in the outcome. If
the difference is small, then we can say
you can look our results seem to be sort
of [inaudible] to behavior. If the
difference is big, then what you gotta do
is you gotta sit back and think. Okay
which of these three makes the most sense.
And regardless of [inaudible] modeling,
whether it's the, just the [inaudible] of
the world. Whether it's [inaudible] to
understand data. Right, [inaudible] the
logic right, or whether it's to. Design
something. Strategize in some way. It's
probably really useful, to think about all
three classes of [inaudible], in the
context that you're considering. Thank